c'est une histoire de ouf et là parce
que ça ça c'est un truc de fou là une
histoire digne des films d'horreur un
enfant de 2 ans a été attaqué par une
horde de rap pendant son sommeil
où ça ça
tournevilliers
apparemment il s'est affamé il ira non
non je vous jure que c'est vrai
l'incident a eu lieu dans une maison
louer à Walton un quartier de Liverpool
on a une vidéo pour vous regardez c'est
un cap non non ça c'est chaud parce que
là alors je vous le dis j'ai j'ai étudié
là dessus les rats les souris maintenant
ils en ont plus rien à [ __ ] de nous
dans mais maintenant avant autant avant
d'arriver tu faisais du bruit la souris
partout maintenant tu arrives le rap te
mets des compressions moi j'ai vu des
rats qui voulaient mettre des coups de
tête
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de l'influence
dans le PAF tout ça tu peux leur faire
des menaces ils en ont rien à [ __ ] tu
vas voir tu feras jamais de téloche
je vais te griller sur les réseaux et
tout non il n'a rien à [ __ ] donc tu
fais 2 millions et tout je lui ai dit
Hanouna je fais des bêtisiers sur France
3 plus de 5 millions connard le rat s'en
fout total non mais je vous jure et là
maintenant les rats n'ont plus peur de
nous et je le dis et il y a une seule
personne qui est responsable de ça c'est
Anne hidalgué
elle a donné une confiance au rat comme
vous le dis Anne Hidalgo a donné nos
conférences les rats maintenant sans
vous des limites il y a des rats qui
viennent faire du shopping avec quoi
dans la voix je jette deux t-shirts qui
me dit tu me prends pas je m'en fous de
présent tu vois non mais c'est un truc
de fou non mais tu te fais dépouiller
par des rats tu serais qu'un sac et
donne-moi des donne-moi ça non mais
c'est un truc de fou les rats sont
partout et à Liverpool regardez ce qui
est arrivé ça fait flipper il y a de
plus en plus de maisons d'appartement
partout en France en Europe ils sont
infestés par les rats le meilleur moyen
c'est des chats c'est vrai ou les
chattes
moi j'ai décidé un truc je vous le dis
pour l'instant j'ai pas de rare
je vais acheter deux chats je vais leur
mettre un brassard sécurité sur la page
[Applaudissements]
dans la maison le meilleur moyen c'est
le chat je vous le dis tu es lâché trois
chats et une chatte
ah c'est pas bon
la chatte en clair du coup pas eu trois
chats les chats du coup vont s'attaquer
à la chatte plus qu'aura bon n'importe
quoi ça sera la chatte à Daniel
elle va me la prêter allez c'est parti
regardez
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs années les attaques de
rats semblent se multiplier les rats
vont-ils dominer le monde il y a
quelques temps un homme avait même fait
tristement l'actualité à cause d'un
rongeur en fait il est décédé du
septicémie suite à la réflexion d'un
morsure cette fois-ci c'est une mère de
famille qui est tombée sur une véritable
scène d'horreur en entrant dans la
chambre de son fils j'ai entendu mon
fils de 2 ans pleurer depuis son lit et
quand je suis entré il était couvert de
sang je suis tombé à genoux en état de
choc et au visage par un rat l'enfant a
été transporté en urgence à l'hôpital
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien avoir la vie de
Guillaume Genton le grand défenseur de
la cause animale
devrait avoir le droit de vote
qu'est-ce que tu dis là dessus non mais
sans est-ce que les rats peuvent non
mais je suis aussi moi un grand
défenseur des animaux mais de toute
évidence il y a enfin c'est un problème
et puis surtout on sait que Laura génère
aussi plein de de maladies et de
problèmes donc
on est obligé de faire quelque chose ça
c'est évident ça devient chaud et oui
3,8 millions de rats à Paris le dernier
chiffre combien d'habitants il y a 2,1
million d'habitants 1,75 rats par
habitant
3,8 millions à Paris il y a le couloir
des rats vous prenez Sébastopol le Grand
Boulevard vous tournez à droite à
Strasbourg Saint-Denis ça s'appelle le
couloir des rats non il y a des rats
partout mais moi je prends ces bois dans
la rue dans la rue mais dans la rue mais
le soir à vous marchez sur le boulevard
Sébastopol des rats vous accompagne
[Rires]
non mais ça fait peur
alors ils attaquent maintenant oui ils
attaquent maintenant ils ont plus peur
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire et moi
je vais faire je vous le dis je vais
faire un exemple je vais aller là-bas
dans le boulevard des reins je vais
prendre un je vais le défoncer
je vais l'attraper je vais le défoncer
une logique qui va partir je vais
défoncer le rat et je vais dire aux
autres voilà vous avez vu ce que j'ai
fait ça servira d'exemple et c'est ce
que tu devrais faire toi là la prochaine
fois non mais je te dis que c'est vrai
parce que là les rats ils n'ont plus
peur je te dis de toute façon ils ont
peur de nous ils ont vu ça fait eh ça
fait 25 ans que les rats et c'est pas
des idiots ils ont vu que en fait on
sommet quand ils arrivaient donc ils
sont bien maman franchement est-ce qu'on
les défoncements en fait vous savez
pourquoi il faut arriver là tu mets une
grosse pluie comme ça comment tu vas lui
mettre oh là comme ça dans la gueule on
est mort
non mais ce qui est vrai c'est que les
rats étaient utiles sous la terre et
nuisible au dessus Hidalgo a beaucoup
beaucoup creusé bah forcément les rack
est en dessous sont montés au-dessus et
au dessus bah ils ont commencé à vivre
comme nous ils ont mangé les mêmes
choses que nous donc maintenant ils ont
les mêmes goûts que nous et maintenant
ils sont tellement sens c'est pas
identiques aux êtres humains que
maintenant l'être humain et son ennemi
le confinement leur a donné beaucoup de
confiance au confinement beaucoup sorti
pour un confinement et je vous l'ai déjà
dit si c'est un rat faisait 25 kg on est
mort il saute il nous saute dessus c'est
ma grand-mère avait des roulettes
25 kg il faut que tu marches tous les
jours j'ai pas vu hein
et si ma grand-mère en avait qu'une
instance
d'éléphants sous terre
et si tu verras quand les rails vont se
mettre à bouffer comme nous dans les
fast food parce qu'ils sortent le soir
il fait dans les coffres ils vont
devenir obèses et qui vont venir
t'attraperia qu'on va voir qu'est-ce que
tu vas dire
[Rires]
c'est pas non plus voilà ça va quoi non
mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai vu des rats
la dernière fois j'ai vu un homme avec
un
sondéas s'invite au restaurant moi
maintenant je vous jure je ne peux plus
aller au restaurant sans regarder s'il y
a pas d'érable pour moi mais partout
ils se parlent entre eux et ils ont une
excellente mémoire ça veut dire que
s'ils ont été dans un endroit où ils ont
trouvé à manger ils vont communiquer
entre eux ils vont tous revenir au même
endroit pour reproduire ça donc une fois
qu'ils viennent c'est foutu revienne
éternellement
mais tu sais que les on fait beaucoup
d'études sur les homosexualité chez les
animaux le rat serait plus sensible à
l'homosexualité que d'autres animaux
absolument notamment les rats qui sont
devant les rats éclaireurs les rageux un
peu les garde du corps quoi
il serait très sensible et très bah il
serait un peu en forme facilement
études encore en cours c'est une
allemande mais les rats serait plus gai
que les autres animaux
c'est pour ça qu'il soit
banane non mais je sais pas pourquoi sur
le marais mais tu vois il y a peut-être
un le Race toi tu sais pourquoi
en tout cas on sait pourquoi on fait pas
des records d'audience quand tu es là
ce soir dans le boss du jour on a parlé
du quid il y a un instant tiens Delphine
toi la grande marin la grande défenseuse
des animaux tu dis quoi sur les rats là
non mais bien sûr non mais s'il commence
à attaquer les humains c'est pas
possible il faut trouver quelque chose
pour cohabiter
avec moi à choisir moi je le défonce
parce que je le dis au racisme je le
défonce voilà je le dis non mais moi
déjà avant que vous le défonciez je le
fais sortir non non
je te le dis s'il y a des rats qui
m'écoutent
ils viennent pas m'embrouiller moi je
les défonce je te le dis ça ils sont
très intelligents ils sont très
intelligents ces animaux ils sont jamais
seuls
je les défauts attention je me suis
battu avec un rat une fois 15 je suis
pas sûr que 15 ans
de bière j'ai une cicatrice ici
il a pris mon doigt je le tapais contre
le mur il voulait pas me laver et je le
dis les rats c'est comme les chiens je
le dis tout de suite et puis les mec ça
sert à rien de les tu fais quoi alors je
vous dis si on vous mord pas du tout les
étrangler c'est le meilleur moyen il
faut les prendre là
tu le prends là Laura et là il est
obligé d'ouvrir tu vois ce que je veux
dire vous avez envie d'en découdre avec
je suis en train de me vénère moi j'ai
Laura tu le prends là là je te le dis ça
sert à rien de le taper j'ai tapé par
terre je me suis fracturé
ça ne sert à rien le rat il te prend le
rat si tu veux qu'il ouvre la bouche le
meilleur moyen si tu l'as tu les
trembles je vais y aller c'est toi là tu
mets le mal avec moi je t'ai pas dit à
ferme ta gueule
en ce moment
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai la j'ai la phobie des rames ah
ouais il est souris ouais ouais je peux
devenir j'ai un rat une souris qui était
venu ici qui est très fort pour les rats
bien sûr mais je le fais venir chez moi
tous les jours
c'est bon pour l'instant il y en a pas
voilà hein c'est un Ratman voilà c'est
le roi du rat il a il a un slip voilà
c'est normal
il est génial